can i tell you why you're brilliant too
the table is nice and tell me when
you're ready yeah tell them you're ready
pat okay we can start whenever you are i
like to start whatever table this table
tie there is nothing more important than
your just you're tits up when you go to
get on someone's podcast and you're like
hey guys like you're just such an
asshole or you're like up here and
you're out of frame or your stomach when
you when you sit down you look like shit
and we know that from being on chelsea
lately for so many years if you sit on
that fucking couch you look like shit
when you sit on when you're sitting and
also i'm saying this is yeah on behalf
of two people that have incredible body
incredible and we're so young and hip
too
christina and i have turned this corner
where we're
oh chris
everyone knows who's here it's just the
mid conversation is so she always tries
to get me to do an intro and i'm like
like
you don't okay
oh dark people confused this is how
we're going to start doing other people
sound like this so look what is this
no you're playing if people are going to
press play it's gonna be like the table
they're gonna build a play
on their beta they're specified what
they go siri play that fucking shrill
cunt yeah that's just the table
true cunt can you call your next she
wanted to i wanted to do like bust what
was it busted horror i want to do what
like i was going to go the special of my
the title of my next special will be the
most common
thing people call me on reddit or
something oh how good and i couldn't
now how are you reading those comments
are you comfortable
yeah you're so over it now you're so
good
i this is i hope you're going to think
i'm a scientologist or something after i
say this but
and we'll talk later about the sure the
chemical tools we used to
delete old thoughts and stuff maybe it's
just chemical tools we've oh drugs
i've done too many of those to put that
shit together please also do a podcast
called mom brain and it's you just
people just no and it's people asking
you about your past i'm like like when
you were 25 who were you dating and
you're just like i don't even remember
what i had for breakfast yeah are you
kidding me
mom brain it's just christina trying to
think of what happened in her life i
don't know who am i anymore we show you
photos of your teens you're like where
was this picture taken and you're just
like ah
russia that was roughly russia yeah wait
but do you read are you are you
so do you read your
comments so here's what you're doing
i'm like i did do full disclosure i did
do
uh that auto blocking feature on
instagram
it actually really holds a mirror up to
you because you can go in and you can
auto block
anything that has certain keywords
and my keywords because you have to go
here
if a comment has this word in it it
doesn't go up at all which is like i'm
like
busted
cunt poor
fucking cunt like the list of words that
i had to put down was very depressing
but people still managed to get around
it i think for me i'm just at a place
where i'm like and i did do after
ayahuasca i had a little bit of a
help with this and just maybe it's just
as i get older i'm like i'm happy like
i'm i'm happy with what i'm doing yeah
and if i i didn't sign up and maybe it's
just because we're women or whatever and
like i never thought this many people
would ever like me
i was told you're never gonna make it
your piece of shit you're not saying so
i'm like i've gotten all this being a
piece of shit who's done funny like i've
been good you mean to tell me you were
told you'd never make it because i feel
like you you've always been really good
at the business and really good at
advancing really or i guess just when
i'm you're reading comments you know
what i mean like oh sorry people people
other comics that were shitty in the
beginning
or like you know stuff like or it's my
own inner monologue told me that you
know and i think that as soon as i
stopped agreeing with the negative
comments they stopped affecting me well
that's because that's the secret of the
negative comment it's that that
motherfucker
found a chink in your armor because the
comment resonates right because if it's
a comment that's nonsense then you're
like it doesn't affect me but when they
find the thing well when you're happy
oh somebody yesterday was like and i
post a picture of tom and i going to my
birthday party dressed in like 80s
attire and i was like i know i'm so sad
you couldn't be there the cutest it was
the best party and um and i was like i
never read comments about myself because
i'm not i don't i don't want to know and
some guy was like young face old neck
and i was like motherfucker
yes i know
you don't think i know but i was like
because you know how hard it is to to
get the neck to look good that's a that
is a low blow yeah that's a low you go
after an old woman's neck
you fucking caught like at least that at
least
at least
show me what you do with the movement
but it's like they didn't call me fat so
that was cool
comment like old neck here's what i'll
do because
can because you're already you're it's
already nettling you it was already
nettling yeah nettling someone said the
thing that you're like this is just me
yeah i'm the only i'm being i'm being
dramatic it's not that bad yeah and then
someone said someone else said it and i
go no no i gotta fuck now it's a thing
someone else said you're in a monologue
but why are you not mad at yourself for
roasting yourself like that yeah
that's it someone stole a joke you
fucking bitch yeah it's like you're not
allowed to talk about me like that yeah
only i am yeah you fuck
yeah that's right i should have thought
of that well those people are a word i'm
not allowed to say do you remember what
we just used to say retarded all the
time emily you might want to leave for
this yeah i was thinking the other day
about this
why should you have to leave i'm just i
just we used to stay retarded okay oh i
say retarded so i'm just saying even if
you say a little we set
in when i was in middle school high
school not high school probably middle
school we would walk around just like
yeah like hey like yeah teachers would
like do it you're retarded are you
fucking retarded
yeah you would just like
like hit your side of this funniest
thing oh my god my aunt worked to find
mentally she would always i when i would
be like is this person retarded she goes
bentley challenge melee challenge she
would have them in her home because she
would help find them jobs that was like
what she did for a living and none of
them ever did that
so it's like i don't even know who we
what we were doing
that's the offensive thing is you guys
were inventing affects
a thing that wasn't even true but it's
still like
to think that as kids we walked around
because i'm like i had mentally
challenged people that we lived with
in my aunt's home she would get them
jobs at grocery stores and drive them
around and help them with the and i'm
like there was no connection between
doing that yeah and them yeah i know we
never put it together that i was making
fun of them but here's the interesting
part as whitney cummings growing up in
dc right is that where you were across
the country i grew up in the san
fernando valley we all went
to everybody so how does it transfer on
the playgrounds all across america how
do we our internet before
in the 80s how let me tell you what else
is like i'm obsessed with universal
things like
oh wait and then i have one for you
i think i'm doing this right okay ready
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah what about mash what is this
remember
yes
how did we all play that game hey what
was yours i bet you got everything you
wanted
i don't remember playing match what was
it mary mansion alley
a weeded mansion apartment shack house i
thought that you could do someone that
you married too okay
yeah and then three lines for three boys
three numbers and then three cars and
then that's your life that's your
fortune duh
your fourth hand
like
my call i remember my coach my like
basketball which was what are you
fucking idiots yeah like what like it
was so adults did it two kids
why are you fucking retarded all the
times there are times to say all the
time uh that and uh
oh my god do you remember dude dude this
one's so sweet it's from the 80s
remember that deaf lady that she would
teach you phrases and she'd be like
spoon spoon i love you with a spoon
goodbye for now and it should go by for
now shimmer bye for now youtube get
outside for now see the thing about
emily is she's the most sensitive but
she
bye for now you remember bye for now oh
my god it would air on saturday morning
cartoons maybe it's just a california
thing it was a deaf lady and she would
teach you phrases in sign language and
she would be like yeah and she'd be like
bye for now and she would say it every
time
everybody knows that they grew up in
socal office bye for now
[Music]
it just takes forever to say it like you
say it
like
bye for now deaf lady no this is gonna
fuck up my algorithm this is called it's
a good sign and she would teach you
oh good it's a good sign yeah and she'd
be like literally like
pompous it's from the 80s mandy harvey
maybe
that's a nice brunette lady ah and she'd
be like host i love you i love you
i love you with a spoon
i don't know she was like what could she
teach you like two or three things
because she get together
she'd be like i love you i love you
spoon spoon put it together now i love
you with a spoon bye for now it's a good
sign and then that was the whole thing
oh
i'm gonna fucking make you watch this
because you'll love it she was great
dude there's a lot of like
important women
and like just people in general you are
not picky you're an important woman i
mean that's why helen keller was awesome
okay helen keller i just read did you
know kel helen keller she was giantly at
the time accused of plagiarism what are
you talking about this is how much
people hate women comedians like how
could she plagiarize plagiarizing what
they're like this bitch's life is too
good
plagiarizing what how could she play
yeah she couldn't really she played was
she's gonna go touch everyone's fingers
yeah how did she
fucking braille this book dude
what is she feeling zips on people's
faces like what are you what are you
talking about
no but i think it's like i remember that
any time i'm like why does this person
helen keller was accused of plagiarism
like any time like someone thinks i'm
offensive or someone thinks i'm like
this happens to the best of us
by the way you know who fucking came in
there's all these articles about it's
like and mark twain came in and helped
her through it like i'm sure he
did i'm sure uh yes he was um
uh she was uh
accused of that and then plagiarism but
did she write novels well then a lot of
people were like it wasn't really her
writing yeah no shit yeah
no
shit
i hope she plays your eyes yeah i hope
so like well isn't it enough that she
learned to speak and read i mean that's
enough in a lifetime given her
circumstances i thought that's all she
did by the way i didn't was like you
think she was really blind yeah like
that's how he fucked up like just let
people
i do that a little bit though that's
kind of like like when celebrities need
to like announce like some disease they
have that no one's ever heard of you're
like
i don't know
i'm big on that would be like this is i
don't know this is i'm getting to this
stage and people like i think i have
depression i'm like no
you're bored yeah because if you have it
you know it like you have to you
wouldn't be say you wouldn't be saying
it you'd probably be like i don't think
i'm not sure you would just be i don't
know pretty fucking crying we wouldn't
be talking exactly no you're just living
fucked up yeah sometimes fucked up shit
happens you're just in it you don't have
time to report it sometimes some people
you people need that i need that
sometimes like i remember
blessed are the people that are
sometimes like
you too by the way we were in um
we were i just love people that are very
direct about their ability especially
when we're perceived by so many people
and looking through the mirror of how
other people perceive us
you when we were in texas uh we were
talking about something and
i was like i said something else oh you
know when i was a kid like i guess like
i was
technically diagnosed as autistic like
we don't say we didn't say that back
then but i was like yeah i'm technically
like
like on the spectrum with like
asperger's and you went that actually
makes a lot of sense
it was like it was like i watched
everything just come together i said
that out loud
and then i was like i think you're
autistic if you just said that out loud
that's how you can diagnose people tell
people you're autistic and if they agree
with you they have it
i can't believe i said that out loud i'm
sorry it was no it was so funny because
i feel like it solved so many of your
problems with our conversation you were
like ah
all these like can i tell you okay so as
long as you i'm glad you brought it up
because i was like
because i did i came home i'm like tom
that's what fucking whitney told me i'm
like she told me she was diagnosed with
autism like when she was a kid and i was
like doesn't that make all kinds of
sense and he's like
okay well
i'm not on the spectrum enough to play
basketball in my 60s
with two small children at home
i know not to play basketball after 40.
i know that is so and i i'm like oh my
god because your personality because
you're so good at like
deduction and like the way that your
brain works i was like oh dude that
makes so much sense like how you're
you're very methodical and like just
organized and type a and da da like i
just see it and i'm like that makes so
much sense with you i i don't know i
liked it i was like i just had a ton of
time i and i and by the way i don't know
like
i'm
um i uh
also have a really hard time reading
faces it took me a really long when the
when people were in masks i was like oh
it's terrible i think everyone had this
problem but it made me realize how much
i need to watch people's mouth move when
they talk
because when someone's just talking and
i can't see their mouth move i can't
understand what they're saying so i
found myself in this like
like and people put on your mask i'm
like
i can't hear if i can't see someone's
mouth move the whole mask thing it's so
funny like i well i obviously complied
and i wore them and then you're just
like
that was why like that it's like
remember slap bracelets you're like that
was weird i know and even like plexiglas
everywhere like the div i'm like really
oh so covid knows it has to stop at the
plexiglass and the cab we will
remember when we were buying a bunch of
toilet paper because of y2k
humans are so like we are such a scaredy
scaredy-cat
group of
hawksters dude
oh god i know like it just was like when
fear is present no other emotion can
exist we were just like in so much fear
when you think about the way we behave i
was just it's like it's like looking at
text you sent when you were drunk and
blacked out oh my god yeah when i look
back at photos i'm like oh my god i was
just washing down my groceries or even
like i don't know if you watched
stranger things this last season there's
a scrap won't
i'm really bad i'll give away things but
um i don't know if you remember this in
the 80s hysteria has always existed but
in the 80s it was towards satanism
everything was about saying no zombies
ozzy osbourne if you listen to aussie
your kids will the kids will be satanic
whatever ac dc satanic satanic and there
was hysteria back then about
even that like we're just so prone i
think it's it's also like this isn't new
like that's the other thing is like it's
it's it's how people can feel her it's
like it's teams it's like the same as
like i root for the cowboys and not that
like you're you're a fucking dolphins
fan fuck you it doesn't only happen in
media on twitter and stuff um
remember when they tried to cancel bart
simpson oh my god it was like a huge
thing at eminem it was like that was
i've recently been listening to that
podcast i mean i love it i just started
listening to old episodes of not blocked
and reported
you're wrong about there's one called
you're wrong about
it's a super smart chick she actually
wrote a book she's writing a book on the
satanic panic oh that's cool she's so so
american smart and she's obsessed with
like cults and and fads and these like
mass hysteria things and emotional
contagion and she and um they go through
in each episode they'll also talk like
revisit something a little bit let's
revisit the anna nicole smith thing like
that was interesting
like what we did was fucked up and like
her yes oh she was a pariah yeah yeah
like let's
visit like if that happened today like
what we did to paris hilton like the
fact that like talk show host just like
called her a whore yeah like in
monologue jokes when personally came on
the podcast i and she's been a friend
for a while but i was like i would just
like to publicly say like i am so like i
did definitely oh i probably wrote i
think i have a million paris hilton
jokes
because i'm going to keep doing them so
i just want you to be okay with that
apologize now they're funnier than ever
yeah and uh who else tara reid there was
another like just people like that and
then he'll uh heard this guy they'll do
deep dives on people that are like
current charlatans like dr oz like he's
not a doctor like he does this and he
tries to sell this and do it so um
they're just really cool and i don't
know why i'm talking about that no i
think you're right there's a i think
you're talking about because there's a
there's a hysteria with everything and
paris hilton that's an interesting one
and i think
i think she became a pariah because we
love to hate her right like she's gone
she was like beautiful and had it also
was like if i'm if i and i think that
this she was shamelessly
wait wait go ahead whitney
go thank you for letting me speak you
got it finally are you ready finally i
get a warden around here raise your hand
um she has a nerf gun that she normally
shoots me with when i interrupt guests
oh
i put it on ebay no nice um
when i trashed paris hilton or made
jokes about her
it made me feel better
yeah and i never in a million years it
didn't occur to me
a joke i made about her could hurt her
because she's invincible and she's got
this amazing life and she's so beautiful
and she's so it's like i i i'm not going
whoa i do think a lot of the people that
make shitty comments to us are like
what's mike why would my com who would
give a shit what i've decided right it's
connected like she is the best ever
however right so okay let's take that
phone like maybe let's take that thought
i agree with you yes and you're right
and at the same time i still think we
should be able to make paris hilton
jokes and i still think that guy on
instagram or whoever can say whatever
the fuck they want about me because
that's the job yeah and if i can't
handle that i shouldn't be in this
fucking job that's correct so and i also
think it needs to exist that we make fun
of those that are bigger and better and
we need contrast needs to happen and we
need contrast it's just that simple and
i think that
sometimes when when someone's being
shitty to me with comments or whatever i
find myself going like for me to expect
everyone i don't know how old this
person is i don't know what their
childhood was like to expect them to
have all these tools whitney call on me
please
christine okay
i just listened to you joey joey diaz
calls me once
whitening so abrupt wayne dyer a million
years ago he was also he wrote many
books uh your erogenous owns as the
first one was great
so wayne dyer says whenever i give a
lecture
um no start back back it up whenever you
win an election a landslide victory is
51 percent think about that
landslide is only 50 it's like when i
read that to be the best baseball hitter
in the world
you can have an 11
hitting rate what does that mean oh that
that that means
you're the best hitter in the league
if you hit it 11 of them wow
so interesting
okay so so so with wayne tyre so he says
whenever i give a talk or whatever and
let's say 500 people show up i expect
that half of them don't like me i expect
it and that way i'm never surprised when
it happens
and i don't take it personally he's like
that's just the batting average
you know what i mean yeah 51
i also find and this is like another way
i always
look you're moving to the airport you're
moving there you start with this this
fucking guy oh jesus
that's where we start with like a new
person yeah you know what i'm saying and
then i have a siri
i can talk to anyone for five minutes
and fall in love with them yeah if i
just ask the right questions take their
time so when someone's like bothering me
that i'm working with i'm just like
where are you from tell me and i'm like
i fucking love this person i just
as we talked about they're insecure
they're trying to not they've ran into
me like we were we just made a whoopsie
we called we made a whoopsie we were
both living our lives and hit each other
and
when someone says something super shitty
about me online my i usually just like
you don't know me dude like if we hung
out you would be obsessed with me
i was like this guy give it up just
playing
yeah it's like or you're saying it's
like gonna be a new fan it's sort of
like
the when
usually when i just respond to someone
i'm like hey dude hope that worked
they're like hey just so you know i saw
this i hope that made your day you know
and everyone else kind of sees it and i
think when
people see like i don't need to get back
at you i need to fight with you because
that's what they want and then when you
just defuse it with like
they'll just move on to someone else
that's what toddlers do to you right
they they're testing they throw shit at
you and they
they they try to fuck with you and if
you take the bait and you go into it
with them you lose the power and because
exactly you're like stupid they're like
i was testing you why are you doing this
we were supposed to say no and smack me
in the head yeah you're supposed to just
hold the the line hold the space for
them to be
to be kids that that's toddler shit
could you imagine could you even imagine
going on somebody's social media and
typing something hateful like it how bad
how but but but here's what i'll say
when we were kids psycho we would
throw eggs at people's homes yeah we
would destroy property
i'll take a comment i'll take a shitty
comment we would hit someone's mailbox
with a shovel driving by knock over a
mailbox like i feel like back then
people go
this knocked over my mailbox and we're
like you left a comment i don't like
like if this is the worst thing
strangers are gonna do to me so true
which by the way just really quick
stupid story about
so toilet paper in people's houses
during the painting things got
shit got dicey there was a
i i don't get bored like i i don't get
bored like i
just don't it's a feeling i just don't
get
and then during the painting i'm gonna
be like i'm bored like i gotta
yeah let's fuck around and dave growl i
had done the movie for um the foo
fighters movie and i was renting a place
in the neighborhood that dave grohl is
in we're near where we shot the movie
and i was like oh my god you live so
close bye and he was like yeah i'm right
here i was like oh fuck shit that night
me and my dude was like dude let's go
like toilet paper house and
we gotta go to the paper's house he's
like yeah i live with this address i
don't know i'm like fucking do it
a shocking amount of time i mean
go and do like each gate like around
each gate the top of the gate like it's
trees are fully i mean we did like hour
40 minutes because he was somewhere i'm
trying not to say anywhere that he was
he was on a vacation and he was gonna
come back that that night so we did it
like six and he was what and
and i was like so okay
so like his like cleaning lady
i
you need to tell me what to do because i
have to go like we went back and like
had to like get it down and stuff but it
was just like
it was we used to do that all the time
yeah that was a different kind of hate
like in our hearts like because you go
yeah fuck you bitch you're probably some
14 year old when he was drunk that was
like
being around i'm gonna i'm gonna ruin
the paint job on your car fuck you
people would key your car and ruin your
car that was that's what humans are
capable of so when it's just like a
shitty comment i'm like i'll take it
psychotic
there's this great uh quote from you
know um what's his name frankie quinones
he does that cholofit creeper yes
he has a sketch where there's this like
white girl that he's trying to fuck or
whatever he's getting with and then
she's like she's she's a kick-away
cholas you know so she's like
back in the day you know if you wanted
to cancel somebody you did it with your
fists and i'm like that is
a hundred percent true that's i mean i
there are some people that do just need
to get smacked in the face baby all
people all these motherfuckers
commenting need to get smacked in the
face i see i've said it for my mom when
i was 11 years old she smacked me in the
face the only time she ever did anything
smack me in the face i hit the ground
and i always say and every time i see
her i thank her for it i called her a
hooker there you go
and had she not that is exactly what she
should have done yeah i will stand by
that yeah you know and it's like she had
gone through a divorce and was like
dating for the first time and i was
jealous that she was like
her my mom and dad weren't getting back
together or whatever fucking bullshit as
a kid and so she already felt enough
guilt and shame that she was going out
with you know dating for the first time
like five years after the divorce she
finally gets it together today and i
think you're like where you been hooker
and jupiter's like wow
and i remember even as i like hit the
floor i was like that was fair
yeah
that was cool mom like i like made me
love her no no you're so funny i'm sorry
i'm just watching you and i'm like
you're just a force of nature what is
what you're just a force you're just so
um
intense and yeah and in such a lovely i
just i love you i don't know you're so
funny i'm just watching this whirling
dervish do you ever just watch her and
you're like emily you're just a force of
nature emily's been with me for nine at
nine years at least my assistant oh my
god i was yeah for three years yeah and
then i left and then i came back but do
you realize like
you left i was pushed out well no and
then you came back and then drove off
and then came back again i just um
think it's time to take a break
emily we need a break we need a minute
oh no
i just need a break it's not you it's me
i need a break no it's not me it's you
it's always that's what i do in breakups
like it's not me it's definitely
let's talk about mental health i must
say i have not um spoken to someone uh
in the last two years that didn't um
have a sobbing episode within the first
five minutes of saying hi to them
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
if you're hanging by a thread we can
help add some threads
because it can lengthen those threats
sick of crying in your car while deep
throating salmon
better help is more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours way
more effective than 42 cupcakes in one
sitting
everybody needs therapy that's why our
listeners get ten percent off their
first month at better everyone i just
saw at the airport in canada does yes
and as soon as you said that i was like
not everyone needs serpents like you
know what
and after whitney's talks these la bug
baggage damn it what is it after whitney
talks to these luggage handlers they're
definitely gonna need therapy i'm
telling you if you have flown air canada
in the last 42 years you should
be on better help yeah and our listeners
get 10 percent off their they take your
baggage and give it back to you at the
end emotional or otherwise our listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney that's better e-h-e-l
jesus christ air canada you going with
bag no you go in with luggage you come
out with baggage that's so good i
stuttered on it so please cut out the
stutter part so it sounds like i
actually was able to say it if we cut
out stutters i couldn't be part of the
ads
that's better no it's good we need a
special needs person on the show
that's our demo
better higher anyone i'll hire people
who can't say words to speak for a
living or read
that's better help her own writing
h-e-l-p-com
which name is that
it kind of just felt like you were
saying to the camera help
atlp help like why are you winking at
the camera emily you know what my
brain's falling apart are you trying to
sneak in a cry for help through an ad no
i'm fine
i don't need to blink twice stop making
your big blue eyes even bigger
you know why i look so healthy even
though i
am in a lot of therapy i don't think
you're allowed to say that i tried for
two years
you can't say it's because of this next
page it is and maybe it isn't but
probably because you're getting that
good dick but unrelated ritual is more
than a probiotic
okay are you farting too much during sex
try rituals they like it when you queef
it's a day how many oh non-binary is he
non-binary i didn't know that
he's your new guy
[Laughter]
did i just fart
no
i did not fart i i didn't fart i cracked
myself up and made myself laugh
i'm sorry my laughs sound like farts
you've been taking more than a probiotic
sounds like you've been taking a
three-in-one with clinically studied
prebiotics probiotics and a post biotic
to support a balanced gut is more of a
bully than the person
who is a bigger bully than the person
who's like did you just fart
on a rolling by the way like had i what
if i did well i
what if i did fart
did you fart do you have a fistula of
the butt you're the one that shits your
pants on your new article furniture
no i need articles to send me more
furniture because i shadow over it
ritual is the one daily capsule for
simple
[Laughter]
well it wasn't like rabbit turds if
you're gonna shit your pants it's not
like it is like a jackson pollock
painting it's like compact logs it's
like
it's like a firework ritual is a once
daily capsule for the simple streamlined
gut support symbiotic plus and ritual
are here to celebrate not hide your
insides there's no more shame in your
gut game i shouldn't have read that
that's why ritual is offering our
listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com whitney to start ritual or
add symbiotic plus to your subscription
today also can you please start taking
ritual not just for yourself but for
everyone else in your life i feel like
being unhealthy is the new like
secondhand smoke like if you're
unhealthy everyone around you has to
deal with it you've been a real ritual
stan since i was a ritual person way
before two years before we had the
podcast yeah because i was so obsessed
with taking omegas to get longer hair
and
and all that and i but i was like i
didn't want to have actual fish because
then you smell like a wharf you're like
burping like when people take fish oil
you know you're like are we a long john
silver oh no that's just craig yep it
also made me burp that fish oil is why i
burped that one day for
24 hours straight can you not bring that
up again
or did you just need attention do you
have any shows coming out
do you
no you do well you're making your lips
all tiny
[Laughter]
when someone's in love with you do you
have to be like would you love me if my
lips look like this
we're not there yet because i think he'd
be like no
he's like 30 little ten when you sleep
you look like that yeah
your lips are very thin like i will be
like would you love me if i look like
this
yeah and he always says yes doesn't it
but it's so fucked no because i'm like
probably not but like
because we wouldn't have started talking
but what it is is it's a it's such a
trap it's like going like
would you love me if i look like this if
you say yes it's like no you wouldn't
yeah yeah yeah you just want to fight
it's a loose leg i just want to fight
with you yeah
yeah and it's like it's like those
conversations where it's like i had a
dream you cheated on me the guy's like
hair we yeah like he knows he's like you
know that every girl any guy's ever
dated has had that dream and he's had to
have this fight before yep yep yep
don't engage people
don't get engaged people
jk
september 8th
i will have just had a birthday so
we'll see
what four days beyond a birthday oh i
thought you were going to say how old i
was i was like how dare you 22 no i'm
not one of those people i'm like you
guys i'm 76. i would love to have this
whole time lied about how young i am
just like
because people lie i'm about being
younger i always like lie about being
older and then like you're just kidding
you guys yeah yeah yeah
i know i got confused that was backwards
i believe it is backwards i i used to
think
so you lie about getting being younger
that's what people do like i lied on my
history why about being older so people
think you look young for your age that's
the ticket
that's the ticket yeah because people
always used to say it was old for that
people were like you're lying about your
age i'm like i would never get away with
this yeah yeah yeah i can't like when
people say like a girl's lying right
you're just like no i'm just this tired
like
because i have to constantly fight
people right i'm just this poor i'm
sorry i'm just like running against the
clock i'm sorry i live with seven
roommates and can't get any slaves right
right
but then because i was always like i
should just lie about i should just say
i'm 40. someone's like you look so good
yeah instead of if i'm like i'm 25
they're like yeah i'm gonna start saying
52.
people stunned i know because people
always say they're like i love your skin
i'm like yeah do you think i'm how old
do you think i am yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i'll
tell you the compliment before it's a
compliment how old do you think you
think i have great skin for a
seven-year-old yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's great
okay september 8th you're going to hear
more bangers like that uh at cincinnati
ohio taft theater uh this is a show that
is rescheduled because i think a pilot
wouldn't get a vaccine so i couldn't get
on a plane it was something ridiculous
like that um
he was at the bar
remember when drunk pilots was like a
go-to
you know you can't even make that joke
getting on an airplane anymore or
they'll have to like test the pilot like
if you get on the plane and you're like
okay you saw you at the bar they shut
down oh wow wow
yeah fucking just like i can't joke
about razor blades in my shoes anymore
what am i supposed to do what are my
things that's gonna be like that would
be a killer joke before you stop being
able to make it it's a loss for
everyone i don't even have razor blades
in my checked duffel bag
you don't even have your jacket the fact
that you have them in your shoes like
oh that's exactly right uh air canada uh
what like what are you guys gonna do
with my luggage like what do you want
what do you want a lot of it ends up at
this weird place if it goes if no one
ever finds it it goes this place in
alabama it's like a secondhand store in
alabama with just all
when can we go there i don't know but it
looks pretty cool i want to go there and
do like an instagram live like everyone
who's lost your luggage follow me
because it's yours judy in atlanta text
me your number i'll get it back to you
like that's my dream show to be like i
found a watch that's engraved i want to
find the owner nothing better than
finding something you
thought you lost yeah because then you
like it's like the psychology of it's
like when um
i returned something that i shouldn't
have bought in the first place that's
expensive
i think i made money oh i'm doing that
later today i'm returning a jumpsuit i'm
500 for sure
no you're six hours poorer
peter potato september 9th i will be in
philadelphia pennsylvania at the miriam
theatre i'm actually really really
stoked uh for that one september 10th
i'll be in richmond virginia the
national emily noonan's alma mall
september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia the paramount
theater and i should be reading these
all faster let's get back to our guest
so i'm trying to stay focused here i
want to talk about negative comments
again like i was saying before i don't
think i ever was told you would get
everyone like female comics are an
acquired taste so i always like yeah a
lot of people are gonna fucking hate me
a lot of people think i'm a dumb cunt
like that's not new i just see it in
writing i used to just
hear about you know what i mean like
this is it is true it makes me think
i've kind of just like made it in a way
it does when you've got as much hate as
you do love tom always said that to me
he's like you know he's like yeah i made
it you haven't made it until you've got
as many haters as you do uh fans and can
you know what someone someone said us on
a podcast sorry not but no i forgot who
the fuck it was it was on she just said
sorry to interrupt how you interrupted
on this podcast
haters are people that don't know their
fans yet
and i think that's such an interesting
way because if you said that tom no no i
wish it was a girl in megan kelly's
podcast there were these two podcasting
girls anyway but that that great idea of
like if you're if you if i'm giving you
an emotional charge
i've done my job
because that's all our job is is to
elicit emotion an emotional response
we're entertaining people you understand
so like
man that's cool and i agree too ketamine
really changed my life so i broke my
ankle
no i've done lsd um as a teenager i've
done those drugs but when i had my ankle
reset on ketamine it's like i had a
near-death experience and um and i all
of a sudden it was like i saw what was
exactly important in life i literally i
ha it's at the end of my it's at the end
of the special if you guys want to hear
it in detail but
um yeah i've been tunnel vision and it
was literally like my husband
and my two sons guys i'm crying now just
fucking sparkly necklace
you think you're better than me yeah
like uh you know and i was like yeah
dude yeah that that's it and like i woke
up just crying and i even now like
thinking about it i'm like oh my god
just that's it that's meaning i feel
such a special connection to you because
you're one of the few
frankly comedians at all it doesn't have
to be men women where i felt like we
were able to like
not always have to like hey what's going
on did it like we were like hey good to
see you like
we could be really really friendly one
night and really really business another
night and it was never personal no but i
i feel that a lot of times you're like
oh i'm seeing this person
okay i really need to leave but i need
to talk to this person the hallway for
20 minutes so people don't think i'm a
bitch and like there was just so much
neediness and brokenness you were always
i was like yeah bitch and you'd be like
i have to head out hey how much did you
make on that gig the other day yeah got
it okay talk to you later like yeah we
could be all business and then friendly
and that's a hard thing to find it is a
hard thing to find i think is like
yeah because especially the comedy store
there was an era
it was so dark in there emotionally dark
that it was like just get in do your
shit and get the fuck out so i didn't
really want to socialize a lot i had a
husband at home and whatever um
but uh sidebar yes i always respected
your professional why wasn't he out
doing fucking stand up why was he at
home
we would take turns we had a dog or
something
um
chelsea lately i just want to ask you
this one question because i want to know
if you had the same thing i did so for
those of you don't know the morning of
chelsea lately
you and i both did the round table uh
for a few years whatever they they would
give you topics at like
10 a.m
and you would have the most stressful
the most yeah but in those four hours
you had to get your makeup and hair done
get your ass down to the west side
because i lived in silver lake so i'd
drive across town and then write
banger jokes for what was going to be
television the number of people i
rear-ended writing jokes about miley
cyrus
i know you feel like we should send that
bitch like i am like like true like the
number of times i almost died yeah
getting that joke about ti
yeah and then you get and then you have
all the great jokes like we're cutting
that topic you're like no
but what was your process because i
remember i would have like diarrhea
just like mine
it was it was i actually started being
pretty strategic about it because i was
never comfortable talking about
celebrities or making fun of them
because i i just like i don't i don't
know it just made me feel um bad yeah
and i
i was like okay what i'm gonna do is any
time there's a topic about someone i'm
gonna find a way to just make fun of
myself oh smart and i'm either gonna
incorporate a joke that's like not
working and it's not good enough for my
stand up but like here this way it's all
of a sudden a joke you know so i would
always try to turn around on myself so
be like so-and-so overdosed on cocaine
it's like well when i tried to do it i
would just try to segue it yeah so smart
gosh yeah because i was such a nervous
wreck those years it was such a big deal
for me to do those round tables and like
and you're competing with your friends
in a way like it's weird to be like
like comedians i feel like it's like
we all are like we know all we're not
competing with each other we're not but
it was like all right i gotta get my
joke and i got you you're ready to like
you had to because you only had such a
such a finite you had to jump in and cut
off your own friends and then it was
just like so embarrassing yeah because
like good to see you did it and then you
get out there and you're like you're not
my fucking friend man i'm getting this
bit in i'm getting this chunk and i
gotta sell out helium motherfucker like
i don't know you and i don't fucking
know you but i like that about you so i
would i would watch how you did it and
that's what you would do and i'm like oh
because i would always watch you in in
this business and i'm like this
and i had to learn this from you
was um
how should i let me back this up even
farther let's go back even farther so i
think back in like oh
6 or 07 i'm working not a day job but
i'm i'm working as a writer and i think
you're working as a late night writer or
you were just done and i was like how is
this bitch doing this and i was so i
think about you that truly every day i
see you on instagram or do anything i'm
like how does how
we've had the same
take on each other no but but then i go
i go wow how is she doing that and then
i would go to my therapist and talk
about it and um but the beauty of you
for me in my life has been like wait you
were talking about your therapist
about whitney cummings i think everyone
else told me that
am i that
triggering you're just very triggering
for people you know what i say i said
that recently somewhere i was like i
think i bring up a lot but it's nothing
to do with you as whitney as a human had
nothing to do with my self-worth but it
had everything to do with going
oh wait why do i why do i feel that envy
i think i want that too how do i get
there now and it but it really helped me
in life so whenever i'm on instagram or
or wherever and you have that
inclination to be envious of somebody
like instead i go like well what is that
oh they just have something that i i
think i want to go that way now so it's
been a really useful tool over the years
so thank you uh
fuck
should i inspire you to be more
successful than me
god damn it create a monster
no i i i i feel so good it's so it's
just so funny to me when i look back at
that time when and you know a podcasting
can be so healing because these
conversations happen and so many people
like natasha legero said that in a in a
way i just wanted so badly to be friends
with you guys and so to think that i was
causing any kind of like
you know
stress in a business that is so unfair
and mercurial and confusing and
especially for us like we're pitted
against each other but my experience
during that time is just so interesting
because i was so not i wasn't like
enjoying i was just like so scared and
yeah
and so i was like i feel bad and i'm
making other people feel bad you're not
making it but here's the difference is
that you're not making anybody feel
anything whitney it's never you're never
making anyone feel anything and the fact
that you were and i think a lot of the
male comics have mentors like very clear
mentors and i and even like joe rogan i
would argue like say that he was a
mentor of mine he very much encouraged
me
but he also mentored so many male comics
under him directly and i think like
watching you you're indirectly a mentor
in a way because you were like
fearless and like no no i want that i'm
gonna go get that and i was like oh
that's what you do like when you feel
like you deserve to have stuff because i
didn't feel like i deserved to have
stuff so i had to learn that lesson of
like dude i deserve shit
okay well who do i talk to to get it
yeah
but that's what you but but you're a
great example of that and that brings up
insecure shit and people that can't
handle that but i also feel i feel like
i have so much to learn from you this is
i'll tell you something that um
i that has been like a little like thing
thorn in my side no you fucked my
husband yeah look he made me wear
your red lipstick
and he made me he's such a he made me
break my ankle it was like nightmare and
get tattoos like sleeves people didn't
like you made me fall down the stairs
like he had this whole thing what an
asshole sorry okay and um no time you
were on ketamine you were fucking
killing life yeah um
and uh
i i will say though it's so funny when
tom was on my podcast i talked
most of the time about how pretty you
are
and
don't worry my neck sucks you know i
know this is gonna fucking cunt but this
is just the same way that anger or
jealousy or whatever it is drove you in
other ways this will this i'm feeling
like this man in some way is going to
there's a gift in here somewhere of
course always there's a gift in here
somewhere always um and uh it's never
them it's you
totally i totally oh
i
i'm here's my deal i
have never really understood how like
podcasting my before i do something i
just like to really understand it and i
think maybe it's like okay being a girl
we always had to work twice as hard to
get half as far i come from sports like
you don't just do something and then
learn later you know what i mean because
my brain was very much like
i was kind of taught like no one wants
to hear women talk for two hours
straight you know what i mean it's like
we were told that no one's interested
nobody wants to hear you and you don't
get to fuck anyone like
imagine i'm like a man listening to a
two women gab that he doesn't get to
ever fuck like that is not your
nightmare
the irony is on where my mom's at it was
meant to be a mom's podcast most of my
listeners are young men
[Laughter]
i'm
okay obsessed it's not the weirdest
thing so it doesn't i think this
generation did they not have moms and
they're using you as their i hope so i'd
love to know porn is number one
baby
i'll take him i'll take them but i think
this gen what the nice thing about gen z
is like they are they did grow up
watching you and me i mean i've been on
i did road rules in the 90s so i've got
people who have watched me as a child
and you're just like oh god which is
like i don't even remember that which is
great like good that means the world is
changing in such a good way don't you
think
it's it's i also think it's like about
the quality of your fans change you know
like it's almost like we it's not about
i mean ideally we have as many people as
possible that like us but when you have
a group that fucks with you that hard
it's hard to give a shit about people's
negative comments you know what i mean
yeah you're just like i have people that
have fucked with me for 20 years like
they got you i look old oh what am i
going to do like what am i going to do
you don't want to fuck me oh what am i
going to do i was all dressed in the
lingerie like
when someone throws shit at me i just
don't wrap that up and then i'll tell
you the thing that yeah was the door to
my side
what was the third in the second thorn
was last time i came on your podcast i
was like
it was before i think i had started
podcasting and i didn't i i sort of like
i i want to know how to do something
really well yeah and i remember going on
being like okay podcast now everyone's
being vulnerable and like talking about
their depression and you have to be
really serious that because every
pockets i've done i go in to try to be
like funny and silly and everyone's like
so tell us about being molested and i'm
like it's like noon why did i drive to
van nuys to this fucking to your
apartment
to be serious
okay when you're on podcast you have to
be
open you have to like reveal a secret or
then a lot of times
people like they're like oh people want
to hear you talk about like the business
like inside business stuff so i remember
come um coming in your podcast who did
you hear that from the everyone how do
you gather your information you're so
you're so funny this way the great
how do you gather the pew research
center um
um it is my inner child does the most of
the work she runs around and uh
it's like either feedback or this is why
i try not to look at comments because
you get a skewed concept of data and
what people want and what people don't
want and most people don't make comments
at all so
usually like if someone's making a
comment to weigh
them
harder it's just silly because they're
probably fucking insane but
i guess i just got so much good feedback
after i did like tim ferriss it was like
you had all this great advice on how to
manage your time and like how to become
a comedian and break into the business
and i guess i just get asked that a lot
so so you wanted to do things perfectly
and you did your research and you
learned that people wanted you said you
want they want a secret so you have to
give it a secret they want to hear they
don't want to hear about your
molestations all the time
this is like what i'm in hearing i'm
like okay this is what does well in pot
and then i'm going to do your podcast
i'm like i really want to hit this out
of the park these are my really good
friends i want to fucking nail this so i
better come with some
serious
fyi it just like literally we're gonna
talk about farts and i was like
um well i had some good advice ready and
i had sexual assault in college i was
going to maybe
disgusting you're like literally poop
farts
and i couldn't i didn't course correct
fast enough yeah like i didn't just go
oh yeah
just be yourself and be a silly idiot
yeah and i was like i think that when
it takes a very um advanced brain to be
able to let go of everything you've
always been taught and just go oh i
guess i can just be funny and silly
and you know it doesn't have to be
like with all the chelsea lately stuff
pre-written intense pre-thought
well but but isn't that too the blessing
of just getting wiser and older is like
you start to go
like with this this special i was like
i'm going to fucking get a dolce gabbana
suit i'm going to put this this is where
we're going this is what we're doing
this is it's this is time but you know
what i mean like i just i don't give a
fuck i've been locked in my house never
seen you on stage without sequins full
sequence i will riot and boycott you and
get rid of your sponsors and say that
you rape me but this is what hap i'm
just saying like the level of and i hate
saying i don't give a fuck it's not that
it's just like
life is so finite and i think the older
i just had a birthday so i'm very
cognizant of like oh god it's ending
it's like have fun try to try to live
because this is not going to last
forever and you know what else and just
a little business cheat like my brain
sometimes i have to go the circuitous
route in order also it's more fun to
watch yeah
when someone's in love with life and
having fun
better yeah like it's like that's the
main reason to do it that's true because
you're better at more people like
watching it
when you're watching somebody's like so
clearly like needs it so bad and you're
just like i can tell this energy it's
it's it's too much because when you're
not having a good time you it feels like
pressure for other people that is the
secret sauce though isn't it fun having
it's it's got to be fun yeah it's got to
be fun i do want to ask you this because
i'm trying to figure out if i'm going to
get married and have kids yeah and i'm
just curious i did i actually wrote this
down um
do you have to
if you're married sure do you have to
say sorry if you're not sorry and just
sell it the way you would fake and
orgasm fuck
so here's the deal man
it's not saying sorry when you're not
sorry
it's
it's a deeper manipulation than that
[Music]
it really fucking matters
it's so much more advanced than that
i've told you the story about um
when i saw you and tom at jerry's deli
on ventura in laurel canyon
no he was doing comedy on a box
we used to do a comedy on just random
like boxes from i don't know school
plays remember jerry's deli next door at
the kibbutz room was a stand-up yeah
that was a great place and i would i saw
you guys there once this month like
literally 18 years ago and i was like
good luck
so like
okay
mom's gonna like i remember
that's gonna last
like you were like watching with your
notebook and i was like cool guys you
think you're gonna like stay together
fuck it's like 20 years later
but he's tattooed on your arm look at me
i've stopped tom forever i've got my
knuckles
um
but the truth is i think you have to
find somebody that you have the same
where your mental issues connect
so we both have a very our issues just
line up so nicely
and then it's also learning about that
person over years and years and you go
like all right i know what that is i'm
not gonna touch it it's respect it's
more about being respectful
and i wish he'd give me a fucking
brace can i tell you the best thing i've
realized is that your husband is not
your 15 year old best girlfriend
so craig shawn the rapper was on my
where my mom's at podcast i've been
obsessed with her i love her so much
shout out to creation
and she goes she goes you know what i
want christina i just want an enmeshed
15 year old girlfriend relationship
and i was like
that's exactly what i want to do
and that's i think i had carried that
into marriage for a minute where i was
like oh well that's it's not an adult
marriage and no
yeah that's your partner like you guys
are part we're partners in many ways but
like if i saw tom doing like let's say
he fell off a rock wall when he was like
motherfucker i'd be like i'll see you
later i'm gonna go with the kids
facetime bird that sounds like great
content
get me a second home please
go buy the porsche second home in tahiti
let's just stream those please but like
you just turn on the camera and leave
yeah yeah totes like you figure this
shit out that was i did a movie about um
neurology it's called the female brain
yes and it's like you can't imply
anymore that men and women have any
biological differences which is what are
we doing um but yeah uh i i met with the
the woman that wrote it the
neuroscientist i went to sausalito and
she was like explaining everything to me
i spent the day with her because i was
like playing her and i was like just top
line if if if women or whatever people
could get from this movie men women if i
learned one thing from you today like
don't throw big words at me like what is
the best piece of advice you can give
people and she went your boyfriend is
not your girlfriend
they have 20 minutes you have 20 minutes
max and it's not
you know like all of our attention spans
are changing now whatever but it's just
like you're not talking about your
sister's uh your sister's wedding you're
not talking about your brother's new
girlfriend and her fucking highlights
you're not that is call your girlfriend
and that's why it took me so long to
understand oh healthy
romantic relationships you have to have
healthy friendships yeah because if you
have toxic girlfriends yeah you come
back and make she fucking didn't show up
and then she fucking did this and he's
like why the fuck and then the healthy
ones you get to go talk about all that
dumb bullshit and gossip
and then he just gets to you know
do his thing and
and and
you know he's got his life to live
you've got your life to live and you
want to like foster that for each other
i think that's how you do it you know
and if you have kids that's a whole
other dynamic
here's what like
what okay so
yeah go ahead i'll tell you everything i
know i'm just obsessed because there's
just little things for me and i i grew
up i think we've had a similar-ish
upbringing where we had to be very
precocious and kind of take care of
ourselves very young
and be the adult very young and i'm so i
think that maybe sometimes i over
correct with having really harsh
boundaries because i don't i know i
it's a relapse in codependence if i
start taking care of an adult
in any way that's not your husband you
know or if i start being codependent
worrying about their feelings or trying
to control their comfort level yeah or
i'm like i think they're in a bad mood
so i should like start offering things
that start perfect like just that shit
of like walking on eggshells and trying
to make sure someone's okay yeah which
is my old shit growing up
but like i'll go just like make coffee
in the kitchen if he's sitting there
like
do i have to
offer him something
right like what's the protocol because
that's literally what's stopping me from
getting up is taking care giving
well i'm just saying i don't want to set
a precedent that this is always going to
happen okay i'll tell you i'll tell you
what's up seriously real talk here's
some fucking shit
this is what you're going to learn
because i lived with a dude before i got
married to tom and i made all the
mistakes that i'm
i made a lot of mistakes in the guy that
i lived with number one when you're with
a guy don't ever fucking do his laundry
don't ever fucking do his laundry you
set that precedent from day one that i
don't do your laundry homie that's all
you or we have a housekeeper the
housekeeper does it i'm telling you i
never did tommy's laundry not because i
don't love him not because i give a shit
about the skids in his drawers but i
don't want to resent him when i'm full
you
know
and then he hasn't done anything wrong
he said nothing wrong well why did you
do we did i didn't know you didn't why
did you do that if you didn't want to so
so if you know what if you know it's too
much
outsource it i think the the greatest
thing he and i ever did he and i have
never spent weekends scrubbing toilets
even at our brokest when we lived in the
fucking rampart division we had a
housekeeper
because we knew that that would breed
that's too far so you do what's
comfortable
i like to spoil him i feed him because i
know that's what he loves right tommy's
into food he likes croissants or
whatever the fuck it is i'll make sure
to bring him home treats every time
so like even now if he's still home i'll
bring him i'll stop by you know we used
to live around here too i'll stop by
macaroon what is he a fucking king of
england he loves what the fuck he loves
croissants why does he eat like marie
antoinette does he's got the best taste
like that emily i'm like who else emily
used to eat do you still ate a chocolate
croissant every morning yeah
that's for like once a year when you're
in france for a wedding we're all dying
like should we why would i not you much
quicker
you know what i really love like my
white trash upbringing um those hot dogs
with the chili injected in the middle
say the ones with the cheese in the
middle too yeah frankenstein's oh fuck
dude we used to take hot so good dude
hot dogs and you would just slice them
down the middle and put cheese in them
fuck the shit i mean i the
bagel bites yeah dog i still fucking i
still i still fuck with bagel bites i
get them for my kids know what i don't
hate stovers all that frozen shit dude
dude can i tell you with my epiphany so
we have this i have this thing on my
podcast called pajitsuki effects where
you realize stuff you should have
already known love brohem bro bro i want
did i not fucking realize that french
bread pizza did you know this think
about it it's a fucking piece of french
bread homie cut it in half i did not
know this where did you where are you
i just thought it was a pizza from
france i was like oh this is like french
pizza but i would get the frozen shit
i'd be like it's just french you know
like they do it different
hey guys
you know me you know me with all my
energy you know me with my
blathering mouth my liquacity
my endless boundless energy that makes
you guys think that i do a lo
everyone get all that energy i sleep
like a goddamn baby which which means
nothing because doesn't that mean you
just like screamed all night yeah
which means i scream and shit my pants
all night
that's all i always thought about taking
candy from a baby
like it's gonna be so easy taking candy
from a baby have you ever tried to take
anything from a baby they flip their
shit
you'd
lose um who gave babies candy in the
first place
wait oh it's like taking care of a
baby's an easy thing yeah but it's not
they've no way no one thinks anything
with babies nothing is easy with babies
there's a lot of those adages that are
don't we keep saying them but they don't
they're not real yeah they'll be like uh
he's as hungry as a cat yeah yeah yeah
happy is a clam oh the thing's known for
emoting
things that look like old gray vaginas
yeah yeah they go like bombed yeah they
look depressed
nick also my friend nick he always
points out
things like that are um inherent
oxymorons like jumbo shrimp yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like i love shelly guy you're like that
is such a
happy mom
so i don't get oh
happy wife happy life i guess if um bowl
and branch now listen very carefully i
have spent my entire life fighting
insomnia taking crazy sleeping pills
fighting like going to bed and just that
that's when the
stress begins my work day starts at
midnight when i get in bed when your
eyes close and it's taking me a long
time to realize that like
it's not about
my brain and what i did that day or what
coffee for me it's just about
are the sheets
cool and crisp enough
and do i feel
like a literal
princess princess well and also thread
count is a myth because it doesn't
matter how many threads there are if
it's just shitty threads you know what
i'm saying so like something can be like
10 million thread count not if it's
straw it's like getting like a gift card
at long john silver's right for a
thousand dollars which yes also gift
card for diarrhea bowlin branch uses the
best 100 organic cotton threads for the
superior softness and for a better
night's sleep it has over 10 000 stellar
reviews they also give you a 30-night
risk-free trial with free shipping and
returns on all orders which is
unbelievable i've never really like
thought about sheets before but when
bowling branch sent me these i i mean i
had a problem getting out of bed before
i've never heard your shoes before like
like what juliet louis had in fear yeah
they were like from cape fear i think i
had slept on the sheets that i was
conceived on because they were literally
from the 80s and they were just they
were soft but they weren't they had tear
stains everywhere tear stains
the annual summer event is starting soon
but bowling branch is giving our
listeners exclusive early access before
anyone else to 20 off with promo code
whitney at bowlingbranch.com this is
their best offer of the year before the
holidays so act now that's bowling
branch b-o-l-l-a
and
d-b-r-a-n-c-h dot com promo code whitney
for 20
off
merry christmas i fell asleep just
looking at him
it's happy holidays
oh my god race is toxic
is toxic racist
[Music]
did you fart
that was the most bully that's blonde
shit dude that is a blonde bitch
did you fart
because now everyone thinks you did fuck
you know there's nothing i can say
if i say no i'm defensive but i said it
like admit like i was shocked i heard a
fart sound and i was laughing no that
wasn't that wasn't like did you that was
like why do you need to know like who
cares if i did
why would you call me out i said it
through laughs
that's how you said it
i i don't know
i you've seen me laugh for 10 years and
you know how i laugh and all of a sudden
today but i've never heard you fart
that's probably true
and as you shouldn't no one's that's not
i'm big on no one should hear anyone
fart yeah no me too i'm good no i just
it's weird that i haven't so i was
hoping today it's not weird have you
heard your friends fart that's not
normal no you're right i have i don't
believe you should have heard that you
know what doesn't make me fart mud water
the coffee alternative with four ad
adaptogenic mushrooms with are your
verdicts
okay
mud water wtr mudwater murder see that's
how you know it's cool it's just an act
they don't know that you need vowels no
vowels necessary yeah it's a coffee
alternative with four adaptogenic
mushrooms and ayurvedic herbs here's the
deal guys
coffee's cancelled i've tried to get
racist and toxic i'm just saying racism
there is finally an alternative
available that is not
some weird ass it doesn't come from like
a weird plastic bag that you have to
order off reddit that's like some coffee
alternative spelled wrong that has like
like it's wrapped it's like you get it
off etsy it's like wrapped in a diaper
with like duct tape this is a real
company
and they made mud water it gives you
energy without anxiety without jitters
or the crash of coffee each ingredient
was added for a purpose cacao and chai
for mood and i know please drink that
and a micro dose of caffeine lion's mane
for alertness lions
you're alert call lord michaels she's
got some impressions on dad i'm a lion
you're a
lion of pasha and apostrophe
lion's mane for alertness
a measurable talent as you just saw from
emily
cordyceps for help to support physical
performance
can you really form for us physically so
i just performed an impersonation of a
lion shotgun reishi to support your
immune system turmeric for soreness and
cinnamon for antioxidants which is like
a game changer mud is wholesome now you
know i i was eating cinnamon by just
putting in a spoon and swallowing it i
was snorting it
mud is whole 30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten free vegan and
kosher certified what's your folger
do people still drink that no
mud water allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash go to mudwater.com
whitney to support the show and use code
whitney for 15 off
and it's
this is weird because this is the only
one i'm confused about the website and
it's the only one that doesn't tell you
how to spell it
m-u-d-w-t-r yeah it's the oh that's how
cool this company is they don't care if
you find them dude most
most ad reads at the end we have to go
like blue bottle b-l-u-e
we know and this one actually is a
little bit like tricky tricky and
there's like it's fine
that's how cool
they are they're like if you can't
fucking figure it out
we don't want you to have our products
if you can figure it out use our code
whitney yeah
wtny
back to the show
i want to ask you about hungarian
ancestral trauma but when you i'm gotta
know i haven't asked someone about their
own sexual trauma in a while and sexual
trauma is real it is the realist but
what is the and it's not only just
you're getting raised by someone that
has but like you've inherited trump
what's wrong
well let me tell you what mine is okay
so hungary
fucking before that they okay so world
war ii so it's that's as far back as i
know right world war ii my grandma gives
birth to my father in a tiny village in
germany she flees on foot
uh with a baby and uh my uncle to back
to hungary so then anyway world war ii
happens the germans fuck up hungary and
then after that the communists fuck up
hungry so it's two
major wars destroying and then the
communists destroy central europe and
eastern europe for the next what 40
years in communism
so i mean you know russia you see how
cool they are with ukraine yeah pretty
cheap
that's a cool regime right to live under
like so and hungary was a beautiful
country has its own culture its own
language was part of the
austro-hungarian empire and was just
fucked ravaged and so my parents grew up
in severe poverty severe restriction
with language with what you can say what
you can do the government will throw you
in the fucking gulag if you speak out
against
the regime so i'm very excited
that is at a time when
like it was also word of mouth or
something like you didn't have receipts
it was like i heard this guy spoke
against the government oh like
there's no way all of it was right oh
and children would be encouraged to rat
out their own family so and you had this
horrible incidents where kids at school
were being taught like hey if your kid
if your parents say something
anti-government tell and kids would do
it because they're children and you
would yeah gone gone so this is why i
don't like this i i hate it when people
are
restricting other people's speech in
this country and makes me fucking nuts
because it's a slippery slope dude it's
terrifying and
you sh well i think for me what it is is
like we should be so lucky to be able to
talk shit about our government we should
be so lucky to say this the same types
of thing like
even if you don't agree with it thank
god we're able to say dumb shit yeah and
not get thrown into a well yeah
a hundred percent why aren't you uh
appreciating and having gratitude for
the fact that we are allowed to talk
shit about our government and
yes not disappear it bums me out but
anyway speaking of generational trauma
so yeah so there's all that and then my
parents escaped from communism in 69 to
canada and then had me in canada and
then we moved to la in 1980 so i'm not
even born in this country my kids are
now first generation american so that's
how fucking much like trauma whatever
we're working out here and so like i've
been through so much therapy to try to
like
just make give them a chance of being
just you know american kids like normal
whatever and you know what i think i was
thinking about you last night i was like
what do you talk about and i was like
why don't i have a kid yet and why don't
i like what's how am i gonna talk about
this with her and i was like i think
what i'm realizing and
is that such a big part of why i like
haven't yet is i'm waiting for when i'm
gonna be the perfect mom oh yeah it's
never going to happen and that doesn't
you
you don't and
no one wants a perfect mom what that
would be
what does that even mean what does that
mean look like i know you know what i'm
saying there's no such thing and
i go like that's so i don't know i think
we spend so much time being like fuck
our parents fuck everyone that did
everything before us they didn't have
tools they dropped the ball i'm kind of
like you know what i'm
it's i'm i'm i'm fine you're fine i've
got here you know i mean there's a lot
of like really i know in my life what is
painful and what isn't i know like i
have tools to get through it and it's
kind of my choice at this point if i
want to feel sorry for myself or not
absolutely and that is like it is a
choice whether i'm going to be happy
today or not if i choose not to be
that's my that's on me absolutely if i'm
going to feel sorry for myself or be
into my victim shit or whatever i'm
going i'm going to still talk about what
happened to me when i was five it's over
man
stop it and then just like and my dad
didn't why are you so obsessed with your
dad were you in love with him yeah it
just is sort of like he was there as
much as he could have been i don't know
what to tell you like it's just sort of
like they're limited yeah everyone's
limited you're dating a new man and all
you do is think about your dad move on
he's the one that got away but you can't
help it like but here's the fucked part
about all that is that you can't it's
unconscious right and and the crazy part
about having kids is like depending on
what age they are will trigger exactly
where you were at that age emotionally
so that's why that's why it's tricky
because if like let's say like for
instance for me i'm i'm four years old
that's the year my parents divorce uh
when i'm three we move to america and so
like that's those are like heavy things
to happen to
i'm not saying like
boo who's me but but so watching my kids
at that age you unconsciously relive
that feeling okay now i'm never having
kids i was like no i'm i'm fashioned and
i was in the past
but you'll really it you can't help it
okay then in that case when i'm four
i'll just leave for six months and let
someone else take it i'll come back for
your most traumatic i'll leave it like
six a.m yeah yeah like i'll pop in and
out it's a disaster it's crazy
what have you had that like yeah like
see i think for me like the my shrink
was like yeah the because my parents
let's say we're about to divorce so like
one through three my parents are
fighting we move countries so like so
one through three for me is really hard
with my children because they're so
needy and vulnerable and it's terrifying
when they get sick or like but do you
see yourself being like i was like this
and going helpless and i didn't like my
mom because my mom was borderline and
schizophrenic so her touch and her
comfort probably didn't feel you're just
sensitive
[Laughter]
i don't know were you just jealous i was
like
that she was having more fun than you i
don't know or were you just needy i
don't know
but so so you know what i mean yeah and
i relive that so then there's this weird
thing that happens once they turn four i
calm down i calm down because i feel
like four's the magic number because
four is the year my parents divorce and
now i'm free meaning i'm out of the
yelling and the chaos of their marriage
and my mom and i are living in an
apartment complex and we're on our own
and my parents are apart isn't that wild
it was apartment complex it was all
immigrants it was like persians israelis
armenians french like and i would just
rock in this community dude i would just
like
i would fucking just roll around and
like go to my friend's house here and
eat armenian food here and then go to my
friend here and it was so free
and i loved it it was it was so it ended
up being really cool and i feel like
that's you know i got to learn about
people and life and
all this shit from this uh you know
single mom whatever existence and i it's
the truth i'm trying to really have like
you know because mental illnesses aside
all that kind of stuff like
i don't know i look at like now it's
just like the the older i get the more i
feel like my
parents like i'm like whether that was
good or bad like i benefited from that
yeah whether i won't do that to my kids
they'll get all the same stuff a
different way but like i've done so much
work and i'm like
that it was all a win for me yeah it was
all this prepared me for that like i've
had to do a lot of work but i'm like
when when this happened this prepared me
for that and oh good so i didn't get
this and this hurt and this is how it
paid off for me later like that's how
that's how i've been able to get that
like peace and resolve and not like
i'm like i don't want to be obsessing
about my parents for the rest of my life
i want to live my life as an adult but
you have to when you go into therapy you
have to do it for a while so that you
can reframe your story which is what
you're doing yes and what like i've done
in fucking a decade of therapy and when
you realize
resentments towards others is drinking
poison and expecting the other person to
die
you hurt me this whole time i'm not
gonna continue hurting myself
like i'm gonna put a stop to this right
now yeah like it's so this this ends you
know and also we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace yeah it's like
forgiveness is for us
you know what i'm saying like yeah well
i don't think also too when you you look
at human behavior and you're like dude
really think about it how much shit is
actually done to you
like legit done
yes there are malicious
things
nine times out of ten everyone's in
their own fucking thought everyone's up
in their own shit they ain't even
thinking about you so maybe they were
disrespectful or then you know some guy
bumps into you at the fucking coffee
shop who cares like he ain't thinking
about me it is so water off a duck's
back at this point it is so
you get to decide and it really is it's
the insecure narcissist i'm a piece of
shit at the center of the universe right
the idea of like everyone's spending
their day trying to fuck me like no one
cares i'm gonna go run into it i fucking
hate her i don't it's just like they
don't know what's happened they're all
on there nobody's looking at their
negative comments on their facebook like
she doesn't like me like everyone is in
their own spiral and even the people
that are acting out towards you it's
about their shit it's never about you
dude and i and i think that's something
and to circle back to about the comments
like in something that's really mean
nasty
i will
write back sometimes
i hope that did
what you wanted it to do right like i
hope i hope you achieved it yeah but i i
genuinely do because my thing is like
like you said before we're entertainers
we're supposed to conjure emotion in
people and it is my job to make your day
and if you hurting me made your day if
that's
i just hope it worked i'm saying you
zing me you son of a bitch this is like
christina was downstairs i just
renovated my the house and she sat down
on this like outdoor swing and she just
looked at me and she went so
did it work
and i was like what it doesn't work now
like did it work like did this house fix
everything
and i was like kind of
kind of kind of well like i i have this
thing because i you and i both grew up
with not a lot and it's like
listen motherfucker
don't tell me your life sucks if you're
a fucking millionaire fuck you do not
tell me oh
yeah shut up go pay for therapy you cunt
go fucking take your alexa pro go get on
a treadmill work out fix your diet
asshole if you've got the resources to
fix this and you're not it is a crime
there's plenty of people that would use
that gratefully for their child's health
care yeah and i do think some people
stop it there is a uh sickness that at a
lack of perspective and i feel like i've
lost a couple friends over that where
i'm just like
what do you mean
just as sort of like the things you
complain about like you've lost yeah
you're touched
like you're actually gone and um but
wait i i do think i do need to ask you a
couple more questions go ahead because i
do need to either get married or have a
kid okay so how long have you been with
this guy
two years but we broke up a couple times
that's okay during yeah it was like do
you want to be married
it's weird because in my head we're
like
married i sound like a guy that i dated
in my 20s we're like we're mayor like i
feel like we're basically married don't
you like i can't i feel like signing a
paperwork we don't have to get the
government involved like i just i think
for again like my perfectionism maybe
takes over and i'm like well i have to
plan a wedding and then i have to spend
then i'm just and then literally my
biggest fear is having a wedding and
having to be sincere in front of all my
friends
that's 100 tom and my teal we were like
we can't do this this is too vulnerable
in front of
people yeah i can't like i can't like i
literally was like if we get married we
can't we either have the roast party
wedding
or the wedding but i can't fuck i know
you mean it's so embarrassing i'm
my vows i will
you will walk away if comics are there i
know
i will make so much fun i will have to
say something embarrassing i know well
then don't invite comics
you can invite us
it is funny because i was thinking about
it i was like if you you can't get
married last minute you have to give
them like a two and a half year heads up
and you get married on a tuesday because
we have to book these venues a year in
advance i know
um okay so i guess i'm just curious if
these are normal feelings go ahead like
i
am making coffee if you want it get it
if i can i walk down the hall and just
like what's up do i have to stop and
talk sure sure
like can we
be roommate like can we
can you ever just co-exist with someone
without the pressure of having to think
about them that's marriage
that's marriage
so so that's that's part of it so it's a
dance right it's a balance of like i
think about you i don't need to think
about you right now
you want i believe i'm a little old
school with how i treat my husband like
i do the european lady model where like
i know i'm not i'm a very like euro wife
in that i'm very tradish
i cook
we i hire someone to clean but i do love
to cook for him i believe in
your kegels every day i do my kegels
my box is tight now i i like to look
nice around the house i don't look like
a piece of shit i don't just wear
schmatta around like a dirty bitch you
know what i look nice that's important
for
self-respect and self-esteem anyway when
you go into al-anon like 12-step program
of adult children alcoholics stuff like
that one of the first things is like put
on a pair of pants and fucking shoes and
a button-down shirt even if you're
working from home even if you're just
hanging out that day
put your hair up yeah
it's a matter of like self-respect yeah
and it changes your uh self-esteem oh my
god during the pandemic i would just
wear fancy dresses around the house
because i was bored and i would put on
wigs and just to like feel like i'm
doing something i should have gone the
wig route instead of a permanent dye
raft
i remember there were some times i was
like what's going on over there
we have to intervene are you okay i'm
like you went to texas so
oh i did the ultimate
okay i feel like my blue hair isn't as
crazy as you fucking moving moved to
texas jesus christ
is that wild wild well the world is
crazy right now but by the way if they
wait where here's my name what is this a
record place yes why didn't i get that
that was for the 50th anniversary i'm
sure they have one for you fucking send
me one yeah my fucking name's right here
i mean they they maybe they sent it did
they send it to texas
or maybe yeah that's you i know isn't
that cute it's a real record player
it's a comedy store record player
special that we even get to be a part of
this legacy it's like it's wild it's
surreal it's surreal it's very surreal
because when i was a kid growing up in
l.a one time i went to the comedy store
i was like 19 my parents and i had white
hair like i do now and some comedian was
up in the or and he's like everybody
he's like what's your name i'm like
christina he's like tina the albino girl
is here today and i was like
you fucking kind of i love you
and i remember being like i think i want
to do this i think i want to do this
there's nothing better like the reason i
love the comedy store so much for like
there's a million reasons but i feel
like when you come from a painful
background which most people have and
you have these tools to survive in that
environment the war we fought as
children right all these like
maladaptive behaviors and all these like
yeah ways to survive and you get out in
the world and none of it works anymore
it doesn't go well people don't like it
so true being paranoid being
self-preservation sort of being hyper
vigilant like always shape-shifting like
it works at thanksgiving and christmas
every year it doesn't work anywhere else
and then you go and then you have all
these super powers
because you had to learn how to
manipulate and lie and cheat and steal
and like i had to become such a good
liar i had to become so good at
manipulating and then you become an
adult in the world and you're like oh
people don't like it when you do this
personal world in show business it's
fantastic they love it
you fucking hit pay dirt bro that's how
you got it that's how you got famous so
i saw you on the bus on the side of the
bus and like oh wait i'm like how'd she
do that already
she just started
i'm like school is in session amateurs
we're not trafficking children we're
making them stalk yeah you did it i'm
not eating this baby's blood it's a
stock yeah
you should have a fucking seminar on
this and so um
uh and then you like have all these
sort of also ability to be rough like i
grew up watching roseanne and our family
system was rough dude
passive aggressive rough like it jokes
jokes jokes yeah and
going in the comments and you're like oh
i can actually like feels like a warm
hug i think a lot of people feel it is
like toxic but just sort of hey
motherfucker hey idiot hey whatever and
i think it's really right
and it's
this is gonna you know uh get me in
trouble i'm sure but i think that also
maybe just when you're a female comic i
mean you were with you know tom for so
long but
i'm so unattractive to other male comics
just as no just as a why would you date
the person that's like there was just an
instant to me let's not shit where we
eat with male comics yeah same z's tom
was the first one i ever did anything
with but there's this nice feeling of
just feeling weirdly asexual around
yeah like there's no like am i looking
there's it made me realize how much i i
spent so much time and energy i was
thinking about male approval oh that's
interesting until i was with a bunch of
men
that love women but i was neutered and i
got to just like not because i you know
what i'm saying yeah i do know i had
real issues with
my own femininity uh i think because i
had mom issues right like
what level of femininity is okay which
is a big problem right and stand up at
least for me the first 10 years i was
always trying to play down my looks i
don't want to wear a dress on stage i
don't want to look too feminine i don't
want to show my boobs i don't want it
because
it's a lot of dynamics that i think i
over thought yes when in reality
everyone's like just be funny just be
funny and then i'm like i wear sneakers
or wear my backpack on stage hair up or
down constantly and then you start to
realize like i think
you know everybody wants inclusivity and
all that and i'm like the best thing
about comedy is that
it's the great equalizer dude like
knowing is a fuck if you're fat if what
color you are what gender what that that
i thought if you're crushing you're
going to get mad respect from all your
homies all your peers are going to be
like that's what's up by the way also
doesn't matter famous
so uh something that i like makes me
love you more and more
every day is like you're the most famous
you've ever been and i feel like as a
stand-up you're working harder than i've
been you've ever worked hey you know
what i'm saying you know what's funny
though i don't feel famous when do you
feel famous because i don't know if i
feel it because i think people like i
feel like my peers were like oh you're
famous my stepsister the other day was
like you know you're famous right and
i'm like i don't know i don't know i i
gotta get you to commercial airport soon
i guess yeah okay all right we gotta get
you to a grocery shop yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we gotta get you out to an
h-e-b yeah yeah
people are so chill in texas maybe but
but they're really quick just about
about that i don't know i think my in
general my gut to that is mom famous
moms
tend to not feel that because you're
you're your kids are just like oh they
suck everything out of you totally they
don't treat you in the way they treat
you like such trash i don't feel that
they don't fucking
have shit on their chin oh my god you
would die so i was watching tv i was on
so the day i did this amy schumer thing
like the parental advisory show yeah the
netflix special yeah so i was like oh it
drops today kids like i'd forgotten
because i'd already been up at 6 a.m
with my kids and i'm like dude i'm on
fucking netflix today dude i was like
come on let me see what i look like come
on i wore this crazy outfit and my kids
could not be less interested and i was
like just look at mommy and they're like
we want to watch fucking fairly odd
parents and they're like look at me i'm
wearing feathers for fuck's sake
somebody's noticed no no you have like a
major career dysmorphia because your
children are emotionally abusive to you
and
yeah i think so it is you are really
like but that's probably a good place to
be i think that's probably good because
i think if you took it in it probably
would be very confusing disoriented and
i think when people
yeah are too aware of it it doesn't it's
not healthy it's not good
because we've seen so many people
implode in our business and i i think
that's a good thing about like i've been
at this for 20 years it's been a slow
burn it's been really crazy by the way
thank god when i thank god when i think
about like
all the stuff i didn't get that i really
wanted i'm like uh thank god i didn't
get that opportunity before i was ready
i thank god
i got to do this special at this time
when i was so much better i mean i feel
like we're just beginning i feel like
this is just the beginning for us you
know i feel like
like
there's something cool about that
feeling where it's like i feel like i'm
just getting like i think you because
you're getting a stride like yeah like
you hit a stride in your abilities your
skill sets and now it's not panic before
i go to stand up you're just like i know
how to do this i'm good at this i got
this and i know what to do if a b or c
happens like i have all the shit in my
back pocket like there's no way i can be
thrown and also i think there's a
like in general there's a comfort that
comes with i mean being in your 20s
you're insecure whether you're a
comedian or not
you know and then it's like being
insecure about your body you're looking
all this shit it's just like the amount
of bandwidth i spent on that the amount
of energy and life force i spent on that
you know and now it's like so much more
fun to be able to um be on stage not be
insecure about it i know and don't but
don't you wish you could
have your brain now in your 20 year old
body and then you would just be like no
because i didn't have my boobs yet
fuck that body
fuck that fucking splash as an
asymmetrical salad or dolly painting
bitch
i know i'm jumping around but you know
what i want to talk to you about all i
hear is people go like we're more
divided than ever i don't know that's
true
are we we've
divided politically the uncles aren't
talking to brothers aren't talking to
brothers and parents are talking to
children because the way they voted i'm
like remember what happened when beanie
babies came around
i literally remember my mom being like
your aunt is collecting beanie babies
we can't go over there this year for
christmas like we didn't speak for years
there was like she just borrowed money
for me and she she got the princess
diana one and we still it was just like
uh
it was just a
there have been other things that have
divided us as a nation well i remember
if you liked ronald reagan in the 80s
you are a piece of shit you know i i
don't think this is new i just think the
internet has made everything feel bigger
and to that ronald reagan was an actor
yeah like this isn't the first time
we've hired people that aren't qualified
to be in office that's like our thing
yeah we've always like i how quick we
forget he was an actual like yeah he was
in like westerns yes big time and nancy
was i think an actress too back in the
day i watched this documentary on them a
million years ago how diabolical they
were as a couple they were just a good
couple in terms of like they're like a
power couple like the will and jada
dog like
yeah like they were they were they were
good together there's people that are
like that where they just found each
other and you're like ah fuck dude
youtube power this is trouble mr miss
smith yeah but tom i mean tom and i are
good that way like in the podcasting
world too like we're kind of we were
compatible with business too which was
really rare i guess in america well he
has so much respect for you as i do him
and i think you know what helped is he
and i came up with this like we were all
kind of open micros at the same time and
i think because we both came up at the
same time like i saw him starting stamps
that's hot yeah and then to see like if
you just met him already famous oh
i think that's ill so gross i think
that's ew
because you don't see this because it's
just sort of like i don't know there's
something just um
i don't know just seeing how the sausage
was made and seeing all the work that
went behind it because you can get stuff
in this business from luck yeah and
knowing that luck had absolutely nothing
to do with it it's just really hot well
and also the luck but the luck runs out
because we've all known people who they
get
you get stuff really early and sometimes
you can hustle and match talent but
there's a lot there's a huge attrition
rate in our it's been crazy and one
night we should have drinks and play
this game because i love this game
because they're the people i've been
jealous of people have gotten shit real
fast and you're like what happened to
that person
gone and i see people that are trying to
do it oh i need to get an agent i'm like
dude i've we've been around long enough
to see people fuck go up yep you know
and then just disappear yeah and i think
that the longer and harder it's won the
more fulfilling
and more sustainable it is which is
everyone knows that i guess but it's
hard in our brains with all these like
new platforms to not try to like get
something really fast well and it's hard
to hang in there when you're a young
broke person or a young broke comic and
you're just like dude that's great sage
advice oh rich successful comedian yeah
who's already there shut the fuck up
because i remember hearing that from my
elders too like just relax you don't
want it fast you want it slow gary
schandling said to me once you could
never make it too late
wow
and i was like fuck you so are you gonna
hire me or not yeah
yeah can i feature for you this weekend
okay
so next week then yeah cause you look at
all those hustles and everything you do
to get here and you're like oh i wish i
could have relaxed just a bit i wish i
could have enjoyed the ride a bit more
and then there's also like a
thing where it's like all the
avenues that were available for us to
get where we are are kind of no longer
there they're not there so yeah it isn't
so what does bother me when people like
okay so how do i know and i'm like well
uh i guess now they're like well it's
different now i'm like then why are you
asking me yeah you know my advice work
harder than fucking anyone yeah be
better than anyone stop playing videos
games and smoking weed treat it like a
job yeah if if you don't love bombing
get out yeah you know do not expect
anything for the first 10 years and like
that's my advice well i'm just going to
do go then do it your way cause maybe
you have a better one i'd love
do your way then do what we did which
was just like in the dark like fucking
jody foster in hannibal's basement yeah
trying to find a fucking monster this is
a mic or a dick
either
fine then do it your way i mean i
remember taking gigs in afghanistan just
to have a gig
literally went to war zones because i'm
like how much is it twelve hundred
dollars a week great i'm there literally
just to get stage time and to get better
and to know like okay well now i know
how to do a war zone but like like
literally like
not like metaphorical afghanistan i did
comedy kandahar i've been there beirut
yeah
dubai we're like women are have no
rights here
they can't you're not allowed to talk
about sex you're not allowed to have
confidence you're not allowed we can't
tell anyone you're getting paid for this
because women can't get paid for work
i'm like
is this gonna be okay i had to we were
going to saudi arabia and they're like
oh we saudi too well i didn't get to go
they were like oh we had to change the
trip like we couldn't get like security
in order yeah in time how was it
crazy you're blonde so you probably did
fine well no i actually dyed my hair
darker to go in the middle east because
i didn't want to stand out that's
fascinating because when i went to
morocco i was with a girlfriend of mine
her mom is blonde and someone ran at her
with scissors and tried to cut her hair
wow yeah i didn't want to stand out so i
didn't
um but when we went to riyadh some guy
blew up a prince or something and they
were like uh we're not gonna let you go
sightseeing at all we're going to take
you right to the base and i was like
cool
so that was a trip remember um
sheamutash i do what happened to her she
had
i i don't know where she is now uh but
she in one of those uso tours like the
plane like almost crashed i think sean
polovsky might have been on it too i
think you're right and april macy i
think they were all together and the
plane lost pressure that's exactly it
and they went yep it was like a female
tour coming to like
perform dude i remember when i was in i
was in afghanistan we were on the we
were all on a plane with sarah tiana
jody miller
and me i think it was just three of us
right i hope i'm not forgetting fourth
and we're in like one of those planes
where the bat goes down i don't know
we're all sitting in kevlar vests and
we're flying over
afghanistan and just
all of a sudden shots come at us and i'm
like and the guy the gunner
shoots back and i was like did we just
get fucking shot at and he's like yeah
it happens all the time i'm like oh god
i wouldn't do them now gigs i don't do
now because of my children but before i
had kids i was like
oh wow dude we have to do an episode
that's just our like crazy road stories
like when i look at yeah when i look at
pictures of like where is that
guantanamo like why was i in this place
what's that place that chernobyl oh
there was a shop in my bringer show at
chernobyl and i was just there every
night i remember there was a room at
lucky strike the bowling alley that was
a good one on highland and i remember
being like i would work on my timing
because you'd hear the ball
hit and you're like i know i need to get
my punch line in before i say that's why
i talk so fast when comedy because my
god just got to get this out before they
hit the pins and then if he got like a
strike he'd be like or like a gutter
ball you'd be like okay i had more time
because we yeah we would do that uh
hollywood and sarah tiana used to run
that yeah
um and uh
it's just weird like when you're doing
coming up in l.a just the rooms we did
we're still all about the wild remember
miyagi's a sushi restaurant of course
where there was a koi pond in a bridge
in front of the stage
i remember i did all these place that's
so funny gosh and they would it would be
tuesday nights and it would start at 10
o'clock and it was um
miyagi's was like a sushi restaurant
that was very popular and they would
have on mtv jams playing like with the
sound on and you would that's the best
they don't even turn
you couldn't hear us like literally
duncan trussell is up there with his
fucking dummy
doing his thing i know and he's like
doing his thing and like mtv jams it
just was like how did we why did we keep
going why
why did we keep going crazy because
there was a dream
but then yeah those open mics and those
those god but thank god for the bill
words of martini i used to drive i'd get
off of my day job i was which was what
oh well i had great ones i worked for
deak entertainment i worked as a writer
i wrote children's cartoons from the
time i was like 28 to like 32 and then
at 32 i became a full-time comedian but
i love the idea that you go from
children's cartoons to chelsea lately i
did i know i when i was doing chelsea my
last day job was the girl scouts the
girl scouts of greater los angeles and i
literally worked part-time at the girl
scouts and then i was doing like road
gigs here and like short skirts need to
be shorter guys
i would go work at the girl scouts after
doing chelsea lately and i would be like
the front desk of the girl scouts and
people be like weren't you in chelsea
lately last night i'm like yeah and now
i'm here at the girl scouts
making the dreams come true
but i always thought about rodney
because rodney dangerfield it's also
hilarious to me when people see you on
any kind of tv and they assume you have
a hundred million dollars yeah you're
still why are you here you were just on
chelsea lately aren't you set for life
well even joe coy was like yeah when i
was doing the roundtable i wasn't
selling tickets really yet like i was
just becoming a headliner and i'm like
that's wild
um but writing dangerfield was selling
aluminum siding yes and he would do what
the tonight show and then go door to
door and sell aluminum and people will
be like weren't you on the fucking you
killed on tonight's show and you're like
and now i'm selling you sighting like
i'm still not an idiot so you need to go
so much farther in your career to make
money yeah you still haven't made it
yeah you're like until you see my funko
pop
doll
you're what did you guys not do funko
pop
oh my god we're both the youngest people
are you am i younger than you are even
younger than you
is that the oh i think i know you're
talking about it's like it's like a
um square head yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like they're called yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like a little doll that's cute
when a comedian has a funko pop i'm like
okay you're you're you're yeah we're
congrats yeah exactly like you're like a
little doll or whatever um okay
okay
you're here for a while i'm here i'm
here i'm queer get used to it
this is exciting i gotta go soon i know
you gotta go now i have someone here now
i'm like half an hour late for something
but i love you
um i love you guys you know i end these
very awkwardly christine
christine is so funny to me because
you're such a christina and you're so
not a christine i'm not a christine i'm
very i'm christine's are cold
christina's are warm i'm very warm so
true and whitney
i mean what's a whitney whitney's to me
regal it sounds fancy not planned
pregnancy i i was named amanda for like
six days and they changed it
i could totally see who's in amanda
people call me that sometimes it's weird
people like whitney courtney and amanda
yeah you're me due to courtney because
the braid yeah
[Laughter]
am i wrong am i wrong it's the horses
and braves people like courtney they
just say it even if they you know
amanda is a big one i heard natasha and
you talking about how people would
mistaken you guys on the round table
like people get you two of you confused
i think people thought i was chelsea
because i was a blonde
it's that i remember when someone came
up to me and was like i love you on
flight of the concords yeah and i was
like it's not like how did you kristen
okay kristen shaw brunette funny person
brunei like i get how for someone busy
who is another like just wires cross
yeah yeah yeah
yeah someone just recognized me for some
shit i didn't do recently too and i was
like thank you you just have to say
thank you you just have to say i mean
people think i'm the progressive lady
i just saw it
wow my brain just put that in
[Applause]
how jealous was i of flo's career when
she got that campaign
stephanie courtney is her name i was
like stephanie oh my god i would love to
be the progressive and now she's
probably just like she's like a fucking
nightmare can we paint the walls a
different color why does everything have
to be this color
like why don't you guys have this
insurance by now if you don't you're not
gonna get it can we just call it you
guys it's like what netflix did when
they stopped uh they basically said like
we've plateaued on subscribers like if
you were gonna sign up for a service you
would have by now oh wow so now we need
to start charging current subscribers
like
i mean
yeah stephanie courtney she was improv
she was on the show to come back one of
my favorite shows ever as the publicist
like she worked she was a groundlings
person oh that makes sense yeah she's
great how do you end how do you end a
podcast can you tell us
i still don't what are you going to do
now
what are you gonna do now you can take a
shit you're gonna eat oh right this
minute yeah uh i have a friend of mine
and writer that i worked with making a
documentary and i'm gonna go in the
other room and
be on it oh fucking a that sounds like
fun i'm gonna go um
pick up some treats and then i'm gonna
go hang out with my kiddos can i give
you some treats they're cookies in my
face i would
they've been in the freezer for like a
year can i tell you something we've
gotten fortune themed stirs
remember that from netflix and like i
feel like i have so many comedian things
my kids just get a never-ending yeah
like here's brook christopher's
flip-flops
yeah that is so funny do you know my
kids call burke crusher fat sticks
my ellis called some fat sticks and we
did not coach him
isn't that great anyway okay
okay he got the gift he got the gift
we're good that money train we got let's
get don buckwald on this kid
asap uh mom jeans don't be an idiot
watch it don't be an idiot
that's the name of the podcast
i love you guys don't write elephants i
love you i love you i want that ring
i'll give it to you i end this awkwardly
and you know it
thanks mommy
i love you too
[Music]